I read the name of this movie is little
man which he can be read a number of
ways these are their little men like
Greg Kinnear character and there are
these little men like Theo and Michael
when you're looking for the combination
that you're going to get from your
actors you talked about the emotional
intelligence what was it that you wanted
to see on screen with their performance
in terms of how they were going to be
cast and how they're going to act on
film one thing that was very clear to me
early in the process is I remembered a
film that I had seen that was pretty
inspiring in terms of this movie which
was the world of Henry orient by George
Roy hill and it's about two girls in in
Manhattan who were kind of from
different sides of the of the economic
class and they'd fall in love with peter
sellers and and one of the things that i
noticed about that film and in many
films about childhood is what's most
important is that the kids be memorable
that something about the kid needs to
stick with you when you're done as soon
as I cast Thea we had started doing some
open calls in New York and we put up
signs at the Lee Strasberg Institute on
15 street in manhattan and a kid Michael
barbieri who saw the the number pulled
it off and came into an open call and as
soon as I saw Michael who was so from
the city of New York he was very much he
couldn't be from anywhere else to be
honest I had a sense that they would be
a good match there was this feeling and
this continued as I shot the movie that
they were very very different in styles
they were both very authentic but I
thought of Theo is out of a Robert
Russell film I just wanted to keep him
very still and things would kind of
emerged from him and Michael was
straight out of Scorsese and I thought I
needed to let him go and in certain
scenes I needed to let him sort of take
on his own where he where he wanted to
take the scene and be more
improvisational I will just share one
thing with this audience which is over
the summer Michael barbieri was accepted
to the LaGuardia High School of
Performing
I don't know if that's art imitating
life are art imitating art but I want to
ask about a scene that I think is so
emblematic of the way in which you work
in the way in which you tell stories and
that is the acting class scene was that
always written that way or was it
written after you met your actors how
did that seem come together and why is
it so critical to the to the film
because it's what a two-minute shot two
minutes sequence it's actually a minute
and a half okay along but it's a good
it's a good chunk of the movie you talk
about that sequence sure one of the
things that I try to do when I'm i work
with Mauricio Zacharias this is our
third film we've written together we
wrote a film called keep the lights on
and then love estranged two years ago
and now little men and we i would say
ninety two percent of the film is really
precisely scripted i'm always looking
for a kind of cinematic economy not in
terms of financial economy but aesthetic
economy and trying to be as useful with
each image and each word as possible so
i don't really encourage a lot of
improvisation but i find that if about
eight percent of the film is is
improvisational is really about the
characters within a particular world it
seeps into the other scenes and you
begin to really believe in this this
universe that is the fictional universe
that i've created and one of the ways i
go about that is by building those
worlds varied with a lot of details so
that acting class a that's Michaels
acting teacher man named Mauricio
bustamante and and they've been working
together since Michael was nine the kids
in that scene which all really add so
much all the faces of these young would
be actors children actors are all from
the neighborhood in Brooklyn where where
the film is set in Bay Ridge they're all
kids who go to a place called acting out
the best acting school for kids in
Brooklyn and you know though they have
the hope and they have the kind of
creativity of that environment and then
we had some some pieces of script that's
actually a Meisner exercise it's a
repetition exercise and i will say that
that's a Strasburg School that we shot
it in so there's a lot of tension with
the different
style but they were willing and able to
do that and what I like about that scene
and often it's a centerpiece kind of
scene in a movie which which breaks the
fourth wall just a little bit I think of
it as also it's like Carol Burnett when
Carol Burnett lets down her guard the
audience feels really invited in and
there's a pleasure to that so when ira
Drex he doesn't like to have a lot of
time for rehearsal so if you're not
going to have rehearsal with your
FileMaker what are the kinds of
questions that you want to ask i read
that might help you understand the
character what are the conversations
that you're having about the character
that you're playing the questions that
the script might raise in your mind well
but before shooting started I mean IRA
you know met up and we we talked about
the script and we went through it if
there was any questions I had about why
do this why do that who the character
really was who this kind of more not as
talkative artistic person who he really
is and what what are the similarities
between me and him one of which is I'm
not very talkative I'm not a very
outward external person as maybe Michael
is but also the similarity between me
and Jake is that we are both able to
express ourselves through a creative
medium his medium being art and I'm
beating being through my acting and my
filmmaking and and though as you bring
up IRA doesn't believe in rehearsals
what he does do is that he sends the
cast on these little dates where me and
Michael barbieri met together a prospect
park we skated around for a bit we
talked about music movies we liked how
are we doing academically what were
favorite subjects and just got to really
know each other as people and so we were
really able to connect with each other
as real people not just as two people
going into
scene and we have no idea who each you
know who we are so we're really able to
get underneath you know both of our
skins and because of that I feel like
the connection which is in the film is a
really lively real film because it is
Theo this movie is about a lot of things
one of the things that's about is about
finding your way in a new location and a
new neighborhood your Los Angeles kid
you go shoot this movie how much did
being the kind of fish out of water as
an actor affect your performance in
terms of being in this new environment
and what that presented you um well well
what me and my my mom you know came out
into brooklyn we were right next to
prospect park and so we really did you
know for two months lived in this area
and became you know i think very very
embedded in it so maybe at first i was
you know kind of getting into you know
what what the kind of situation was and
where we were how how i can feel
comfortable in it because I not been to
New York too many times but I feel like
as the filming process went on it it
felt a lot more like a like home in a
sense so suddenly everything I saw
wasn't so strange to me like what is
this thing called a subway yeah but I
feel like you know at first maybe it was
a good thing that I was more out out
fish out of water as you say because
this is a kid moving into a new
neighborhood that was one of the first
few scenes that we shot but I do feel
like as the filming process went along
and as we stayed longer in Brooklyn I
was I I felt like I was a Brooklyn kid
ira was there a starting point for this
story I mean I think a lot of people who
know your work would say it kind of
follows almost thematically to love is
strange but were you thinking about
gentrification were you thinking about
becoming a parent what was the genesis
of the idea and is the idea then start
finding a location and a story as you
say I have two kids 24 year old twins
and and so I'm a I'm a
parent i'm also a son and i think I'm 50
so I'm sort of in some very middle point
and and I'm often thinking about my role
as both a new generation of parent and
also what my responsibilities and what
I've learned from in terms of my own
father and that relationship I'm
interested in these generational crosses
and I think this film is really it's
about these two kids but it's also
deeply about the parents generation as
well and the marriage and and and being
a mother and all these different things
so I I wanted to make a film that
focused on childhood in its relationship
to adult life and I also wanted to make
a kind of film that I'm really miss
which is a sort of cinematic film that
has childhood maybe at its center but
that is not animated and it's not a
superhero film and it's a kind of film
like the world of in orient or or like a
movie like cast by Ken Loach or the 400
blows or the red balloon all these
movies that introduced for me as a young
person some of the beauties of
moviemaking and and I wanted to try to
capture that innocence from your very
first movie that delta which is largely
autobiographical a lot of your own life
is reflected in your movies but you also
work with a co-writer so how do you
balance what you feel and what you
understand with somebody who may not
feel or understand or share those
experiences you know it's like it's it's
a collaboration and a relationship and
and and when it works it can be very
beautiful Mauricio Zacharias is from he
lives we both lived in New York for
about 20 years he's from Rio we tend to
bring in bits and pieces of our lives
we're also now a form of family he's the
Godfather of my son you know we are a
communal family in a way when we started
working on this film we had the idea of
a film about two boys who go on strike
which we kind of took from from a azu
film called I was born but which is a
silent movie made in the 30s about kids
who go on strike and I liked that as a
premise
and and then we were like well what our
kids going to go on strike about and and
Mauricio brought he was telling me his
family owned a store in Rio and they
were trying to evict a woman who would
stop paying rent it was the shop owner
and it took several years to do so and
he kept telling me different chapters of
what was happening down with his parents
and one day he came in and he said they
were in court at the time with jet in
front of a judge and and on the very day
they were in court they went to the
store and the woman had put a Help
Wanted sign in the window and it was to
me so strikingly dramatic and also i was
aware immediately that there were two
sides of that story there was Maurice
Diaz family side and there was the woman
who was trying to hold on and and that
gave us a really kind of the larger
texture of the film what we tried to do
was was play that out in a way that the
audience isn't allowed to choose easily
who they identify with there's a kind of
the rich or not too rich the poor not to
pour there there in a way it's a fight
for the middle class and it's that part
of what you like in your movies that you
don't want to have answers that if
people can debate what the movie means
and debate who they're supposed to like
or dislike that you have succeeded well
I feel that I construct things more than
that i'm not i'm certainly somewhat of
an observational filmmaker but i'm also
interested in dramatic suspense and I
think that ambiguity of moral Center
gives that suspense so the audience's is
is really trying to ask themselves where
do they position what position are they
in and the story and what I find with
this film is it begins and maybe many of
my films do they begin in a very open
way and slowly the door start shutting
and it becomes a real chamber peace
between these five characters who are
caught in something that is really hard
to fix Theo and Ira thank you guys for
coming out thank you guys for coming out
for the film as well